President Trump has made insulting the
media a centerpiece of his presidency
but there is at least one member of the
press corps who has earned a universal
praise for his work he's Pulitzer
prize-winning photographer there is his
name is Doug Mills he's captured all of
these iconic images of mr. Trump to tell
the story of his White House tenure
major Garrett knows a majors at the
White House and introduces us to the
photographer who has caught the
president's eye you could say major good
morning to you good morning Gail anyone
who covers president Trump knows he
loves the media and he hates the media
now that love-hate relationship is
usually a big picture thing kind of a
meta element of this tense relationship
and not for Doug Mills because Doug
Mills quite literally and uniquely
personifies precisely what President
Trump likes and dislikes from Ronald
Reagan to Donald Trump and everyone
between Doug Mills has made the White
House his photographic home his lens
overflowing with portraits of
presidential power and prestige
have you ever photographed a president
as image-conscious as Donald Trump never
Barack Obama was the most photogenic by
far by far Donald Trump is the most
iconic why does he make great pictures
obviously his hair obviously just how
big he is and just his eyes I'm just
everything about him president Trump
wears the number 45 on his cuffs his
emotions can often be found there to his
emotions are right out there and the
most amazing photo op I've ever been in
in the Oval Office was with the
president United States with Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer we shouldn't
shut down the government over a dispute
and you want to shut talking about the
last time Chuck you should have no no no
I felt uncomfortable because I thought
at any moment we should just leave this
conversation yet that's part of Donald
Trump while running for president mr.
Trump directed many of his own scenes
such as when he told our videographer
Tony furlough back a little donate
where to stand while shooting an
interview do you feel you develop a
relationship with each president you
photograph absolutely I feel like I've
gotten to know them they know who I am
I go in there with an apolitical mind
president Trump's relationship with
mills pulled him into the vortex of a g7
economic conference
and the second nuclear summit with North
Korean dictator Kim jong-un how does
that affect you it is uncomfortable
especially in front of a world leader
like Kim jong-un to be called out and
say oh this Tigers brilliant worse the
president's relentless attacks on the
New York Times where Mills has worked
since 2002 the newspapers going to hell
when he attacks us during a rally it's
uncomfortable it disappoints me I wish
he didn't do it at the White House elbow
room for reporters and photographers is
limited
Mills philosophy keep one eye on the
president and one eye on everyone else
the president may be the most important
person in the room today but there's
somebody sitting along the wall or
somebody in the background who's going
to be really important in a couple days
so captured the day but archive the
moment yes because moments at the White
House live forever when did you first
know you wanted to be a photographer
middle school after four decades and to
Pulitzer Prizes Mills has developed a
reputation as one of Washington's top
news photographers around the White
House all right Jeffrey goodnight he's
the Dean chief what's up chief stay out
of trouble every assignment that I go
into I'm trying to be creative as Mills
was with former FBI director James Comey
in the eye of another political
hurricane lifting his camera high above
the lashing partisan wins correct at the
time that that hearing took place he had
all the answers he was the main story we
returned with Mills to the Senate
hearing room to learn what it takes to
go from concept to creation I went out
and scoped out where he was gonna be
sitting in the desk I pre focused like a
director you blocked this scene exactly
Mills staked out the spot where he would
eventually make the photograph waiting
for 45 minutes I basically extended the
monopod out and once I got where I
wanted I just started firing from above
Mills photo told a story of silent
anticipation I just really feel like it
really captures a moment of the room
another moment
the president's first State of the Union
with the House of Representatives under
new management that says it all as far
as you know the power play in Washington
lately Mills has been chasing the
photographic dimensions of impeachment
documenting the angry players and faces
of anguished history
I've known Doug Mills for many many
years and if you were standing here Gale
and gang he would say he is unworthy of
this attention that the president and
the presidency is always the story
always the news true enough Doug every
day of your professional career except
today
I know major what a great story so
interesting to see how Doug mel's thinks
and how he works I thought that was
fascinating and because you've known him
so long what can you tell us about him
that you didn't include in your story
very very great piece you know so much
of Washington is podiums neckties pins
yeah and marble statues it's all very
stationary pulling something out of that
scene which looks very familiar day in
and day out takes tremendous creativity
it takes a mind that is willing to look
at what's in front of you but create
something special create something
different different perspectives
different shadows different lighting
Doug Mills does that with the most
mundane story assignment in the New York
Times trust him to do that his career
has established a reputation where that
thing that looks so similar to everyone
out of Doug mills his lens looks
completely different yeah he gets
something different thank you very much
major